[Music]
my name is Ken Cosette my friends
everybody calls me Duker live here in
beautiful Lhasa Alaska is home I work up
in Park Alaska
I am a production operator I've been in
the oil business now about 25 years and
it's great living
[Music]
and where I work at everybody up there
makes a very very good living there was
no reason why any of us should be in
death there's none
but we're normal right my whole
philosophy was credit cards I'll just
work another week swipe the card worked
another week swipe the card I got this
right I was never late on payments was
never behind but I was living paycheck
to paycheck so I rode from Minnesota
over to Milwaukee Wisconsin got on a
ferry went over Michigan see my buddy in
Grand Rapids in the course of that I
blew up my motorcycle so I was sitting
in hotel room and trying to figure out
how I was gonna get back to Minneapolis
so I get back to work I made a decision
I need to get a rental car I'm gonna run
a car to drive back anyway so I'm
sitting there looking at my wallet
you got these credit cards everyone on
the maxed out so I call a credit card
company and I'm begging the gal on the
other end of the phone to extend me
another thousand dollars limits like it
which was $25,000 I maxed out all of
them
January 7th of 2013 and I still carry to
this date and I will carry to my grave
is my debts sat down I wrote them all
out January 7 2013
BAM there it is house dead $395,000 said
ain't living like this for
[Music]
I did it so I had no credit cards and
and I just started hitting it started
with the first one
got that one knocked out I just did just
what they said and just roll the roll
that money the next one next one and as
I got so to the top of my list they you
know it took a little bit longer but
each time I hit them goals man and he
could feel the weight off my shoulders
it was just incredible
[Music]
to have it where nobody owns me anymore
nobody nothing on me except God just
puts you in a whole new level of living
and a whole new feeling of man this is
incredible so I keep putting money away
and now my bank countess keeps going
like this and I you know I don't live to
work I work to live now back when I was
kid growing up in Minnesota I always
wanted to go down the Mississippi River
on a boat just you know the Tom Sawyer
Huck Finn deal so about five years ago
actually when I was still buried in
death told the guy that that was one of
my dream he said he ever heard of the
Great Loop I said no he said well look
it up so I looked it up as soon as I
pulled it up online there's the map I
said I'm doing that that's my goal how
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna do it I put my
budget you know to buy a boat go to that
50,000 I could pull 50,000 chassis pull
that together pretty quick make it
happen so I started looking at boats I
looked at sail boats pontoon boats
trailers yachts Miami plays fast boats
the whole nine yards woke up one morning
I'm looking at a $250,000 boat and it's
beautiful it's dream I love and then I
want to drive one in boat so bad and
wait wait a minute
what would Dave say and I said I'm not
going into
to view this trip so I was out riding my
scooter one day and went by a seadoo
shop huh one well one of them deals so I
pulled in there started to talk to the
owner and tell him what I was thinking
about doing so yeah you can do that up
on these it's a motorcycle on water I
one night right
the great loop is it's all on water go
down the Mississippi River to the Gulf
of Mexico and I'm going to follow the
coastline heavy Dees over to Florida go
down around then to Florida go around
qsr then you head up the East Coast up
the Intracoastal Waterway I'm going to
take that all the way up to New York
there's bunch in a couple of different
ways to go but I'm going with the Hudson
River to the Erie Canal the Erie Canal
I'm gonna get all five of the Great
Lakes
I'll hit Lakes Pier then I'll come back
to Lake Michigan and Lake Michigan I'll
follow the coastline down to Chicago
Illinois where the Illinois River start
I'll take the Illinois River back from
the Mississippi than the Mississippi
back up to Minneapolis st. Paul without
any side trips it's about a six thousand
mile trip through the course of the next
couple years that's my mission jet skis
on water motorcycle riding in between
that and it's gold or whatever and
that's my plan because um I have no debt
it's all cash it's a beautiful thing and
and it's so simple it's harder than heck
when you're going through the process
but once you get there and get that
weight off your shoulders and then to
live like no one else is amazing and I'm
living like nobody else let me tell you
what
I want to make sure that people see me
coming so to do that I have a helmet
that I'm gonna wear on this trip it's a
motorcycle helmet but it's got the bull
horns and it's got hair down the mill
and so it's like a Viking so I kind of
started the trip last year but you got
down to block number three on the
Mississippi River just get close to us
as I pulled up there I stayed about
three four hundred yards away from the
lock so I'm standing up and got the
helmet on I'm standing up you know what
just looking at checking stuff out and I
turn around and left like today got down
her around noontime or so so we're
sitting around there's about six other
boats that are waiting to get in and
start pulling into the lock see the lock
master coming down from the building he
starts yelling and cussing at me you son
of a gun and blah blah blah what the
heck is wrong with you and he done it on
you came down here last night the Sun
was your back and your horns were
sticking up and I thought the apocalypse
was coming to get me I thought my life
was over I said this is crazy
said I wiped my eyes I shook my head I
turn around you were gone
you have no idea I'll have for him to
see you right now I'm going through life
letting people see who I am of what I am
and this is what it's about
you're on the Mississippi River and the
Gulf Mexico you'll see me coming with
the horns on
[Music]
you
[Music]